all right you hear me now
brilliant awesome thanks for coming I
know there is a like tough competition
with so many great talks in parallel so
I really appreciate the time you've
given me hopefully I'm not gonna
disappoint you if I do you what's that
oh if I do just let me know I'll give
you a free AWS credits you know you have
to trade for everything today we're
going to talk a little bit about Kaos
engineering before I'm starting the talk
how many of you practice Kaos
engineering and I'm not talking chaos
because that's pretty much everyone
well how many of you practice chaos
engineering that's very good question
yeah on purpose
right not as as a consequences alright
some pretty much no one I saw half a
hand right so someone was kind of shy to
say that but yeah we all practice chaos
that's for sure the calcium Janee ring
is some something a little bit different
is really trying to break things on
purpose to make more things more
resilient I'm Adrian Holmes me I'm part
of the Technical Evangelist team for a
de Bresse I've been actually lucky
enough to have been working with AWS
technology for about 12 years first as a
as a user and customer and a lot of that
talk a lot of these kind of things I
want to talk of result from all the
failures that I've I've had all the
mistakes I've done so usually that's how
you you can share knowledge you never
share good stuff you always share about
things I guess that's the natural things
so that presentation is actually a kind
of a baby of that so hopefully you can
get some some some goods and Bad's out
of that first we want to start with this
how many of you are firefighters in the
room this one is brilliant so there's
something very peculiar with
firefighters first they are like heroes
they're very amazing but they do insane
amount of trainings actually
before going on the spot and in stunning
firefighting there's about 600 hours
training just before doing the first job
and then after that they almost spent
80% of their time training training
fighting fires and you know why they do
that you're not allowed to answer I it's
very simple they want to build intuition
into being able to fight fire because
when they go on the spot there's no time
to think they have to know exactly
what's gonna happen
you think you basically come you know
really do it fast enough and basically
you're out so they don't want to build
this intuition about how to behave with
fire and I like to think chaos
engineering is very similar and actually
this idea of fighting fire is kind of
long got all the idea in mid-2000
actually in the early 2000 amazon.com
went through a massive growth actually
we where first the big monolith
application we split that into micro
services and our user base grew and grew
and grew and we started to have outages
right because our blast radius started
to increase and it was very natural for
the platform to experience big big
outages so we hired a guy called Jesse
Robbins really Jesse Robbins were the
first amazing software engineer but he
was a firefighter and he brought that
idea of training for fire to Amazon
basically what he wanted to do is call
game days he brought something called
game days we still call those games days
today and the game day is basically he
was going around the data center in
unplugging things literally in
production employed in power units
cables cutting cables inside the data
center and you know simply to test
brilliance of the services and the
platform but also to give practice for
the new engineers into how to deal with
outage and to do this in a kind of semi
controlled environment it went
up till that they actually could hold
the whole data center to test in
production the result was kind of big
bigger than expected so they stopped
doing that but they learned a lot and
basically we still do chaos today every
time we launch a new AWS regions we do
chaos for a few few weeks before the
service open to customers where we try
breaking things on purpose we didn't
call that chaos like that we really call
that game days and basically was stuff
we did what was very very necessary for
us is basically these micro services and
this is kind of the dependency map of
micro services at Amazon and you see a
strong dependence on the bottom it's
actually the retail webpage but any
architect can't make sense of any of
that it used to be quite normal where
you have maybe four or five services
working together where you could kind of
make sense of what was interacting with
one another now in the distributed
systems like that it's impossible to
figure out what's happening is actually
impossible also to have all of that
working and being operational hundred
percent all the time
statistically at any given time there's
always something failing right and this
is kind of reflected in the way we build
things actually and you will hear very
nerve or go city of Amazon saying all
the time that failure is inevitable and
will happen everything will fail so
basically that's one of the things we we
really did a lot trying to break things
and kind of experience with that but
actually the big turning point for chaos
in January in my opinion was Netflix in
the end of 2014
Netflix was already migrated to AWS and
it were in the u.s. East region and the
data plane for the load balancer
experienced an outage and Netflix went
down for few hours and they basically
started to think about how to build
clear out native extremely resilient
architectures and then they to help them
build that architecture and actually
test it they went into creating tools
the first
of those tools where was the chaos
monkey actually I'm sure many of you
have heard about chaos monkeys the first
little guy here in the middle is chaos
monkey and this one was a script which
was like scheduled to run few times per
day and randomly killed servers in
production and that was done so that
actually everything that was deployed
was made sure that it could be resilient
and what's the best way to test
resiliency by just unplugging things and
breaking him so that it forced people to
actually really think about resiliency
as a first class of how you build your
application and then it quickly followed
by what they call the simian army which
was a bunch of tools to test a lot of
other things within the architecture and
then the big gory lie there is actually
a monkey that randomly takes a full
region out of Netflix in production so
Netflix runs in four different AWS
regions two in US when Europe in one
measure and that that crazy gorilla
literally takes region out while people
watch Netflix in production legend says
that they do that once a month while
people watching production while you
watch Netflix and so that's kind of the
Holy Grail I would say of K was
engineering and that's actually also a
problem because a lot of people heard
about Netflix and the way they do chaos
engineering and has started to think
that a engineering needs to be in
production and if you say that to your
manager trust me the first thing is
gonna say you are nuts we're never gonna
do that we're never gonna break things
in production but if you call that
safety engineering or resiliency
engineering all of sudden you have
someone to talk to so it's very fun on
TV and it's very fun to talk about chaos
engineering but if you want to talk
inside your company never ever mentioned
the word chaos talk about resilience
that's gonna be my first advice but
today when you do resiliency engineering
or chaos engineering there's a whole
cycle of things to do but actually the
centerpiece of it is
Injection so what we will do is we
create an experiment and I'll talk a
little bit about that later
and then we inject failure and of course
failure has to go through the entire
stack when I meet customers and I do I
set up the chaos engineering practices
the first thing I do is actually not an
application infrastructure attack is a
people attack and that doesn't mean a
break next to people in production I
never killed anyone while doing chaos
engineering but what I do I identify
team leaders or people in teams that
actually are the exceptional type of
people I had to in my life twice they
were called Paul so I usually call that
the Paul attack those guys are you know
you give them anything they fix it while
looking at you making a joke drinking
coffee and you never really know what
happens we all have that guy right in
our companies what happens if Paul gets
hit by a bus well that's actually the
first thing to test actually so that's
why people people are and I don't heat
them by a bus with the bus I literally I
go there and I take the laptop and I say
Paul today you can go home and the last
customer I've done that three weeks ago
and six hours they were able to live
without Paul and we had to bring back
Paul very very fast and you know you can
think about very complicated things but
that's the first thing actually that you
have to do when you want to build
resilience it's actually business
resiliency right and then you can go
down and you can say okay is my
infrastructure resilient
it's my application resilient and all
that kind of things and there's a lot of
things and I'm gonna show you and demo
some of the tools today with you but
remember people attack because I think
we don't talk about that enough and
don't quote me that I say you should hit
Paul by with a bus thank you
so what do we do that as I said we want
to avoid things to break in production
and we actually through chaos
engineering experiment we want to break
things not necessarily in production but
we're gonna break things first to
understand if they're resilient but we
want to break things when everyone is in
the company how many of you have
I've stayed out night or Christmas or
holidays fixing things because you were
on pager and you had to just go there
and it's never during the day right it's
always in the evening at night's wedding
I had to Christmas things like this
because that's when outages happen so
instead of waiting for that we actually
create a semi outage through an
experiment when all the engineers are in
the room and everyone is wide awake
usually that's a 10:00 in the morning
right if you do that in the afternoon
usually people are waiting to go home or
then they're like eating ten is the
optimal time I've found that is great if
you start at 9:00 is like no I need
coffee
they make mistake really 10 is brilliant
so that's a one thing to do it what it's
not it's just randomly break things I
think that's a very bad image but chaos
engineering has is the word chaos first
is is terrible makes people think that
we just don't control anything actually
it's really controlled and I'll explain
how we we do things and we really break
with the purpose is to validate an
hypothesis is this part of the
architecture of resilient or not and
then we go in verify it so what are the
prerequisites for chaos engineering and
sure you just start tomorrow go and say
Adrian talked about breaking things on
purpose so let's take the database down
well obviously know there's tons of
stuff and I just called the whole
residency stack and you have to go and
make sure your I've done already a lot
of work into your application is your
application resilient I think the most
funny outages are thing is certificate
being expired how many of you have seen
these ones right and it's stupid right
so how can we avoid that you know make
sure that you don't do this make sure
you have redundancy right in your
application if you know the mathematic
behind the systems in parallel if you
have a system a part of the component
that is 99% available that's three days
and sixteen hours of downtime a year if
you put it in parallel we don't do
anything else on the system you just put
it in parallel you jump to four nines
availability that's 52 minutes if you
that three times it's six nines of
availability 52 seconds a year of
downtown so that's simple math and I
think a lot of you already probably do
that
you know scale Horizonte kind of things
or I have duplications of component and
of course monitoring I think if you
gonna inject failure but you don't
monitor well good luck and things like
these also have an alert system that
actually works a very interesting case
engineering experiment that I have had
done actually showed that the alerting
system failed and then we didn't get the
alarms on time so that's also something
you have to be sure right and think
about and of course on the application
level there's tons of stuff how many of
you are listing all the time outs of all
the dependencies you have in your
systems like the default timeouts do you
have a sheet of all the dependents in
your system so that default timer for
the driver calling the database is
actually 15 seconds now that's something
you probably should actually most of the
systems have default timeouts which
either are infinite or 30-minute hundred
minutes and things like this 100 seconds
as well for core for dotnet core the
HTTP request library so it's like in
distributed systems or in the system in
general you don't want to have those so
the first thing first is look at all
your timeouts and make sure that they
actually makes sense then you have
retries and things like I know I don't
want to talk too much about that I've
written a bunch of blog post I'm happy
to to talk about this but today I want
to make sure that before going to case
engineering there are some work that you
have to do of course you can do cows
engineering then in a test environment
and in your laptop to help you build
this one's right and that's definitely
something you should do so the phase of
chaos engine earrings are the following
it starts with on the upright a steady
state eventually your application is
deployed in production or somewhere and
you have a steady state a steady state
is a kind of a figure of is my
application in normal operation
something like this right and usually
people use CPU memory I always say
that's definitely not enough I'll give
you an example at Amazon and the scale
of Amazon the CPU or a memory as
absolutely no meaning what we use is the
orders the number of orders per minute
and we can have very very accurate
predictions of those Netflix use the
pulse of Netflix which is the number of
time people around the globe click on
play button and that's a very very good
metrics because it's a direct
correlation between user experience
clicking a lot is not fun and then a
service being operational being able to
deliver on that plane so they're able to
detect regional faults simply on by
understanding the number of time people
click on the play button so these things
like this what is the normal behavior of
your system usually it's a combination
of business in ops metrics ok then you
have to go into the output assist and
this is the interesting thing is all
right you bring everyone in the room and
you start to ask the question what if
actually this is wrong it should be what
when because everything will fail
eventually so what is gonna happen when
a data business is going down well the
most important here and I said that is
to bring everyone in the room and I'll
tell you why because when you bring the
product manager the designer the you the
database is the backend the front-end
everyone in the room will have a
different answer to start with if you
ask these are UI designer what happened
to my application if I lose the database
I will say 99% of the time I've done
that they have never thought about it
for
and they actually didn't necessarily
care about this and for good reason
most of the teens actually have
separations of of concerns right so
chaos engineering kind of enforced
people to actually think in a global
view about this kind of stuff and
resiliency starts in the UI if you have
a component a recommendation engine that
fails well you just don't want to return
the four four and cross the entire
application you just want to degrade or
just mask that and say you know rebuild
your UI so that I have a component that
fell but hey we can be in a degraded
State in kind of a partial error mode
type of things so bring everyone in the
room what I usually do is I ask them to
write things on paper if you ask them to
talk usually everyone eventually ends up
saying the same thing simply because
they're talking and then bouncing ideas
if you write on papers you hundred
percent have different answers and
that's actually a moment to stop and say
oh why do we all have different answers
then you can go back in you know and
rebuild your product product design and
make sure that some of the result from
those discussions actually in the design
of the product right what is a decorated
state for UI a prime video is very
simple if we have a database falling
down we go into read-only mode where we
serve stuff from cache of course we lose
a lot of customer interaction a lot of
data that could be written but we say eh
it's our fault we lost the database our
customers should never experience any
problem because of our fault so we fall
into a read-only mode and then serve the
content anyway and of course it's a
decorated experience so very important
do that you don't always have to start
with breaking the database actually
always start small what happened if my
load balancer is latency latency usually
is a dead dead listen it will break
stuff so
things I will discuss more about that
once you have picked up one I positive
rights just say hey what happened if my
database my master database go down and
every one a scan is the same see now you
mean it's Eadie then you go into the
running the experiment and that's where
you you know wonder I don't identify
kind of what are you gonna test never
ever test on pain kissed customers first
you can always start with customers that
are maybe internal or synthetic or
things like this you know really you
should protect your customers of course
so make sure eventually you might do it
when you become really good at it but at
the beginning when you want to start
always starts very small say I'm just
gonna do a cannery deployment on the new
with a new infrastructure and there's
send one percent of the traffic there
and then see if I can run my experiment
there that's usually a good way because
then you can have this stop emergency
stop button that is very important say
if your experiment starts to go into an
outage then you can stop it and roll
back and move back the traffic to the
known affected environment which is very
important always keep in mind the idea
of blast radius blast reduces the amount
of customers because your customers are
basically you the whole the gold here
how many customers will be affected
right this is something super important
when you run an experiment make sure
there is no way to have a cascading
failure which would affect entire set of
customers and then the emergency stop
button is also a fallacy in some chase
chaos engineering experiment will
actually write data into a database and
or will mutate data and sometimes it's
very hard to rollback right so figure
out maybe before running the experiment
if there's a chance that your data might
be corrupted and then have a scenario to
to recover from that of course these are
extreme cases but it's something you
have to think of if your experiment ends
up writing something in the database
once you've done that most important is
actually to verify right so you take all
the papers that people have written and
then you verify is that actually what
happened that's why you need to have a
lot of measurement about what happened
at what time and figuring out yeah
actually the the architect predicted
that the failover would take roughly a
minute in 30 seconds these are the
result of the experiment we can verify
this if it's not correlating is then you
can deep dive on the problem and why do
we have a different understanding so oh
yeah DNS caching oh I forgot about that
oh my TTL is actually 300 seconds and
therefore I can't have 1 minute 30
seconds failover
happen to do an experiment we did with
customer or I did with customer a few
weeks ago as well so these are very
interesting to see right figuring out if
you can actually prove your hypothesis
through the measurement and this is why
it's super super important to have
measures of everything once you do that
of course you have to verify your
experiment verify fix your experiment
but before before that actually is
something that is super important that I
forgot to mention in previous slide the
most important thing in my opinion to
detect to to quantify as well when you
verify your experiment is the time to
detect right and this is super important
because when you do an experiment you
don't necessarily want everyone to know
exactly at what time you're gonna run
the experiment so you can test the real
reactions of people and the real
escalation path I'd say one of the big
outage I've experienced was because our
escalation path in the paging system
failed so no one got paged and we got
customers to tell us our system was down
this was pre AWS before I join AWS and
this is a situation where you don't want
to now to be absolutely not so always
always make sure that you through an
experiment you also test the detection
the alerting system so it's like a
reinsurance that in case of a real
problem actually this will work then
what we do at a AWS loss is what we call
post mortems
we write what we call Corrections of
errors where we take a team of engineers
to understand what really went wrong why
why our experiment failed or why it was
successful and we we use a system called
the five why's it's been criticized a
lot but we do many five whys and we ask
a lot of other question me this is just
to start the process of deep diving on
the root Coast and we start from the
altitude say why did we have an outage
because my database run out of
connections why did we run out of
Corrections well because the timer was
Infinite and my client at the time out
of sent ten seconds so every time the
client retried it lost the connection
why did the retry I had different so you
can deep dive and then figure out yeah
my library I imported at the library and
okay why did we import the library and
not check the time out because we don't
have the tools for that and that's okay
that's a big problem
alright so let's build to to introspect
code and figure out all our default
timeout and make sure to allow it
everyone if a timeout is not set so this
is kind of root causes and analysis and
of course from this I could have given
you five or six different sonars
and you should definitely do it the big
thing in outages is never one reason
it's always a collections of small
reason usually happening at the same
time that creates this kind of cascading
failures so make sure that you deep dive
into into into the errors and make sure
you actually fix those and this is very
important never happens so that's why
I'm saying have different analysis on
that and then comes to improve all the
fix right and there there's no secret
sauce here unfortunately but I'll give
you I'll tell you that I had a customer
in three months ago where we did a
casing spare
and we came out of the experiment with a
list of things which were critical and
then really really important to fix the
problem is they continued developing the
features and two weeks after they
actually experienced the outage that
could have been solved if they would
have fixed stuff that we uncovered
during the chaos experiment and this is
usually a tension that happens in teams
are you uncover problems is should you
stop developing features and then really
fix or should you wait how do you always
say fix stuff fast that customers
actually add the 16-hour downtime for
something they knew was a problem so
very important don't let don't let
things like this happen there's plethora
of evidence that if you know something
will bite you it will bite you right and
that's the same with with failures so
improve what we do I'm alone again once
we have a correction of error we have a
list of things to fix we stop all the
roadmap we actually freeze roadmap with
freeze feature branches feature
development and we fix stuff that's our
priority number one and we don't even
have to go to our sea-levels teams that
deployed service can actually take this
responsibility themselves and say we
don't we don't do anything anymore we
just fix that stuff and this is
something that I think is great it's
empowering teams to fix things before
problems happen now I want to show I
want to give you some kind of tools and
and things that are important but that
you can start playing with in production
or in your test environment and I'm
gonna demo quite a few of those so the
bananas for monkeys I always say start
very simple start local I'll give you a
story of what I used to do with the team
of engineers that work with before
joining NWS I was leading a team about
20 people and we were hiring very
regularly new new members and the first
thing we were doing with them
on the first week one was a write a
small tool with three different api's
right to product let's say a product API
that you can store a product you can get
the product you have like maybe a
synchronous API and a synchronous API
and things like this and then we were
asking them to make it as resilient as
possible and that's it and then we were
letting the person kind of figuring out
what it really is and you'll be very
surprised but the results of that and
how simple things can actually like a
docker stop comment can actually help
you improve a lot and I'll show you
actually I still have a lot of the code
and actually I put this code on github
so if you're interested and I call that
code le owner I just love the name a
learner it's the name I want to call my
daughter if I ever have one so I called
my code Eleanor it's pathetic but that's
the way it is sorry and there's a bunch
of different API is here there's an echo
a product API and then you can you know
store things and post so in action it
looks like this this is actually sorry
I'm gonna show you the docker compose
because that's something I often use to
play locally there's an API front-end
here there's a task running celery so
this is developing Python and there's a
load balancer in front and nginx and
then there's a master database a slave
database then a couple of radius
containers to do cache and then also
queue I'm very often I would ask then
people to make this as resilient as
possible right and then you can think
about well the first thing is actually
test with docker stop I think it did
this is very no-brainer so you know like
if you have for example here a health
check you see I have my master database
running I have a slave I've radius
checked so there
so what I can do is actually a docker PS
and then check for master I can take for
example that darker and say darker stuff
oh maybe I should put the docker ID and
you see here this dies gracefully I
always love the die gracefully like if
ever things can die gracefully but then
then just lets desktop you see I have my
health check here that tells me that
there's no operational errors indeed my
master database is not working but can I
still get for example a product so let's
say can I get a product ID yeah a sealed
so this is a very good way to say oh I
can build actually read only mode and if
you would never break the database if
you would never test locally actually
he's very often you would never think
about hey my business it's not to write
to database if I've data how can I serve
that I can do a failover into into the
slave instead you see here there was a
there was no master detected and force a
connection to the slave and that's the
kind of stuff I think that are
definitely definitely interesting to do
so the first simple stuff to do case
experiment is actually docker compose
and docker and then just break your
docker containers and see what happens
very often it will surprise you things
never fail gracefully like it was
written but it helps you to figure out
okay what can I do if I lose the
database what can I do if I lose cash is
my system able to handle a change of of
behavior if I lose cash but I still have
data is how do you handle them and even
if some of those are very hard questions
you actually enforce you to think about
it and I think for us at least in the
company when we set this kind of up it
totally changed the culture of how
people design system because then
naturally they were thinking about
resiliency every time they built a new
component in your API and then
and started to build map of API path and
figuring out the critical services and
naturally enforce an understanding of
what happened if we lose some of those
critical services so something like this
start very simple definitely it's very
important another very very nice way to
test resiliency is to DDoS yourself I'll
I'll show you that again I'm gonna I'm
gonna use this one this is actually so
here the WR k command actually will
start at I think 12 threads with 400
concurrent connections for 20 seconds
and simply will attack the health API
that I was just there and actually
before doing anything here do you
realize the huge problem there is here
massive issue here how many of you have
experienced an outage based on there's
no space left on your instance it's
actually an outage happens super often
and the very important thing here
resiliency wise would have say there's
way too much logging let's drop the
logging right because that's absolutely
an easy way to DDoS someone is force
them to have too much logging that will
take the instance down that's a typical
way attacker is do a DDoS attack it's
not by taking your concurrent
connections out is simply to force the
system to lock too much and then you run
out of space on your instance if your
instance to run out of space you can't
open connections because an i/o
operation needs space on your on your
drive so here a big problem before doing
anything is actually yeah in a
production system I would easily run out
of space so I need to figure out how to
drop that logging experience but let's
do it again because I want to show you
another way so here my health API
alright let's run that again
you see the time it takes now so imagine
what it takes actually a long time what
is wrong with that well there's a
massive problem with actually this this
behavior is that if I am in an auto
scaling group and my load balancer is
looking for health check in the instance
and can't enter and the instance don't
doesn't prioritize health check well
guess what the load balancer is doing
taking you out so it's unhealthy not
gonna send traffic and then test others
and you're removing instance for a note
from a load balancer so other instance
will get more connections and won't be
able to answer else and that's the
cascading failures that has happened to
me several times alright so in a
situation like this very good way we say
how can I prioritize my health check and
say oh the other API is is bombarding it
so well a very easy way to do that is
rate-limiting right so let's do a rate
limit and we take 10 purse
per minute right so let's see that we do
that and then obviously then I'm rate
limiting so though there's another
problem you say of course I'm rate
limiting the same client that I'm
playing with right but in theory if I
have a different client then my rate
limiting should work but you see now my
rate limit actually should be a bit
smarter and say I actually came from a
different client I should probably take
the xip or the client different ash to
figure out the rate limits so it's
actually a lot of different questions
that you can start questioning yourself
and say oh how can I even locally make
this more resilient and I think that's
already a lot that you can do just
starting from that so yeah make sure you
actually play by first trying to DDoS
yourself before someone else does
because you will learn a lot
the application another very cool cool
comment that I really like is the TC on
Linux that will simply add a 200
millisecond latency on your et0 eth0
interface right so do you know Latin see
the problems of latency how many people
have you play fortnight is the same
every time I use these questions
everyone laughs no one raised their hand
it's the same like I mean your view on
tinder it's no one everyone plays that
fortnight I get killed in 10 seconds on
for tonight because of latency because
the kid is usually much faster than me
at answering and actually my response is
usually five-minute 500 milliseconds 600
milliseconds the kids I play with are
usually able to kill in 300 and 400
milliseconds because they've been
trained training a lot and that's
usually the effect of latency if you
want a tangible effect of latency on the
retail amazon.com page we make a be
experiment of adding 100 percent latency
on the webpage and that's an effect of
reducing the product orders by 1% every
hundred milliseconds it's something the
human brain doesn't even realize it just
means that people that experience a bit
more latency won't spend much time on
your page and the more you increase this
actually it's going exponential past a
moment they will just never go back and
that you lose this so we use a system of
latency bucket for our page we say our
page needs to be loaded in let's say
maximum 3 seconds from all the services
and then we cut and degrade if it if
it's not at 3 at 3 seconds for example
depends on which page of course right
but you get the idea so that's very a
very good thing to do and figuring out
the effect of latin-themed one that I
love is actually I don't know if I'm any
of you knew the stress stress product so
small tool on Linux there's an updated
version of it called stress mg now
also helps you to randomly kill stuff
I'll add CPU burn on your environment so
something like this oops I mean the
wrong sorry up I mean the wrong shell I
need to quit okay
I lost my my shell clean okay I lost
that one so let's I want demo this one
but that's a good way also to add stress
in your system I'll show you some other
way that's actually something that you
should definitely add in your in your
tools if you want to randomly add the
CPU burns to your application another
very interesting thing to do is play
with IP IP tables and one of the easiest
way to break your application is remove
access to DNS resolvers so basically cut
TCP and UDP port 253 or you drop that
traffic from the IP table and see if
your application depends on DNS activity
or if you can cache locally if you can
use that that's a very good way of
testing I think local local local
applications as well other fun things to
do using most of the Linux tools already
is as fill up the disk you can write a
massive massive file to fill up that
this can see what is gonna happening
what's gonna happen you can do traffic
shaping to increase packet loss and your
in your interface you can detach all the
volumes and say oh what happened
you don't have discs anymore - right -
what do you do how do you behave do you
gracefully degrade what do you do or
mess with the et cos it's always a very
good way do you have a discovery service
that you can rely on if you detect a
change of the host can you recover from
that
that's it repairing a lot of things to
do if you want to have an integrated
suite of chaos tools there's a very good
one of course from Netflix the seaman
army the only downside of this is is
really integrating heavily with
spinnaker which is a deployment
deployment pipeline tool and that's what
Netflix uses luckily everything is open
source so you can still take the take
the code out of of all that and play
with with the the army but I found it
quite complicated actually
and there's much more easy way to do it
but it's definitely brilliant to look at
the code and get a lot of ideas of what
you can start breaking my favorite is
one one of my favorite is the chaos
toolkit that's a toolkit that is API
base so it's open source you can write
code to test an experiment and I'll show
you how to do that so sorry
this is how you how you would write an
experiment here from the beginning you
start with the steady state hypothesis
so is how is your application responding
in in the normal mode this is just to
show you how the framework with this is
working with my docker compose
experiment here you won't make sure that
the answer is 200 on the health check
and then you have methods to actually do
the experiment and there you see I just
do a docker and I checked
the PID of the master then I stopped
that basically I just do through code
what I did with docker stop and then the
good thing with that is actually you can
integrate into a CI CD pipeline right so
here after that after breaking database
I do a probe on echo
I can pause after let's say I'll do I'll
do a ten seconds here then I really get
my health and then I'll restart my
database and eventually everything
should go back to normal so I'll show
you in practice how this works right
because actually that's the cool thing
so if I do into chaos do you all see the
screen it's good yeah okay and then you
can run start your experiment so
experiment DB down and what it will do
here it will start running my experiment
and you can see of course that here is
degrading the database shutting nose so
it's very nice way to start writing what
I you know some kind of test Suites I
think or experiments and that you can
then run regularly while you deploy
software because very often between
versions deployment you want to be able
to automate and maybe find problems
right so I think that's a beautiful way
to do it and it's very simple to to use
it there's a lot of plugins for
different cloud providers that you can
out-of-the-box start breaking things and
you see here my experiment kind of add
an error right so you can say all right
in this deployment actually in my
experiment failed so then you can deep
dive and say oh what happened and I
think it's a very good way to make sure
you don't have
between deployments or between versions
you don't have drift and you don't have
lights a loss of resiliency as well so
something definitely to to look at this
chaos toolkit actually I want to I can
show you quickly how one looks if you
want to integrate for ec2 this is simply
terminating randomly stuff into into an
every ability zone so you see I have the
chaos AWS and then I call ec2 and the
probes and then I can count instances
and say here my steady state hypothesis
ask to start with there's some healthy
instances regardless of what they do and
then I just start breaking randomly
those instances on so I stopped
instances in that every ability zone
with instances that have this tag chaos
ready but you don't want to necessarily
break all the other instances you want
to make sure that you target the
instances that already so that's
actually quite flexible framework and I
highly suggest that you you look at it
especially if you are interested in
continuous deployment and pipeline for
your chaos experiments then is grimian
grimian is a kind of destruction as a
service so to say it's a company that
was founded by 2x Amazonians that were
part of the resiliency team at amazon so
they have a lot of experience actually
we use similar tools internally at
amazon to to do chaos experiment and
test our services they've done a kind of
a customer version of it now I want to
demo that to you before demoing this is
you see here I'm running I'm running an
architecture which is sorry which is
multi AC so I have two servers to
WordPress instances deployed
across to every bleaches owns and that's
basically what it is it's my wordpress
stuff I can write things if I know how
to use this one post here I can modify
that so you get the idea right I can
start that so basically my application
is working across multiple AZ's it's
resilient if I break one of this
instance it will recover right so let's
test that so to do that gremlin is
actually very nice
what gremlin works on you have to
install an agent in the in the backend
so in the instance I have installed an
agent that communicates with the service
and that offers me basically this is my
agent you see I have two two of them I
can select those again I can start
playing experiments this is the kind of
attacks they have so first kind of
attacks they have resource attacks so
you can consume CPU you can consume
dicks this space you can consume target
IO so all the stuff we've talked about
you can take my memory down consume it
and say how many how many how much
memory you want to take out what's the
percentage of memory you want to take
out from your instance that's a very
easy way to break your GBM by the way so
make sure that if you do that you are
you're resonant on the state level you
can kill processes you can simply shut
down or my favorite one time travel yep
change the time of your instance and see
how it behaves I've never ever seen an
experiment that ended well it's a sure
thing to break it
especially in distributed systems if you
have data okay it's a mess on the
network level you can create black holes
so I mean there's Network never go
through you drop all the traffic you can
block DNS the same
same thing that I mentioned earlier so
why I really like with gremlin is in in
kind of nice UI it integrates all these
kind of things we talked about the
downside is you have to install an agent
and that agent kind of discussed with a
third party service so well you have to
make sure that you can trust that it's
also got interesting it's not the on
demand the license so you have to have
sales discussion I've had the discussion
with cells and back in force trying to
figure out what kind of license I could
have and how much I need to pay my
consumption is which i think is it is
kind of outdated at the cloud age but
anyway I think the product is pretty
amazing so let's see CDC in action so we
selected our two targets here and we're
gonna do a CPU attack for 60 seconds and
let's unleash those ones and I've
connected to my instances you see
they're here and you see the CPU attacks
are gonna happen
so the first one here and then the
gremlin is actually here attacking the
instance and then I can start playing
with with the WordPress how is WordPress
reacting to that so it's not too bad I
want to write a post I want to store
some stuff you know I say is they've
done quite a okay job it's not really a
CPU demanding maybe they'll all just
load a lot of stuff on the on the UI so
that's running what the interesting
thing here is if you detect a problem
you can just out everything immediately
and within second the experiment will
stop right so you see now my attack will
stop so they bring all that out of the
box and I was told that they will
improve their license and sell stuff
because I complained to them so anyway
definitely have a look at agreeing they
have a free
a free tier a free offer that you can
just start playing with and install it
if they support docker so you can
install that on docker as well they do
that on kubernetes as well it supports a
lot of stuff is actually also integrates
with the previous chaos toolkit I showed
through ap is so you can run grimming
through the kale to get CI CD experiment
which is brilliant in my opinion so
definitely have a look at it now a
rather new one but actually something I
really really love is toxic proxy is
proxy that was is open source by Shopify
and it allows you to create kind of
proxy obviously between your client and
your dependencies so whether it's a want
to talk to database ready or to your
containers and you can inject toxics so
let's I want to demo that to you quickly
so here I've have Redis installed on my
laptop I can connect Redis so if I if I
do radius you know I can get foo
and yes it's bar you can set set bar who
okay it's fine so it works so but that's
connecting directly to to Redis what we
don't want that so what we want is
connect through through the toxic proxy
so you see here I connected a proxy for
Redis on port 20,000 that will then
communicate with that so then I can I
can then do something like this 20,000
and you see I can still get my food but
there there is no toxic here right so
let's create a toxic so what we can do
is toxic we can add a toxic for Redis
and latency based toxic that will add
1000 milliseconds latency so basically a
second of latency and now if you test
that you see up and if you get full
it's added this one second licensing so
it's very easy to add in your system if
you have a if you want to proxy requests
to your sequel database and see the
effect of latency super easy to deploy
Shopify does recommend you don't run
this in production
they do say they've hardened harden it
three years and they they've run it
three years in their architecture they
use it very heavily so it's ready for
prime time but they still say maybe
don't do it in production extremely
large scale but I think it's a brilliant
way to start experimenting both locally
here with how your system react and how
your containers might react to licensee
and I think it's a brilliant way to to
interface with with the tools if you are
into kubernetes there is a brilliant one
that is called cube monkey's I won't
have the time to demo that unfortunately
maybe next time the cube monkey is
actually very nice because it's a most a
port of the simian army or the chaos
monkey of Netflix - kubernetes so you
can randomly kill kill kill pods and
that's also something that you
definitely wanna test before pushing
your cube unities cluster in production
another very good tool especially if
you're in using docker is Pumbaa so all
the stuff doctor stop docker start
things like this I get the PID is
actually obstructed by Pumbaa Pumbaa
hello it helps you to that to do that
way more easily definitely have a look
at this is brilliant product integrates
with a lot of stool and then if you are
into adding also latency tundra which
has a product for most mostly
to monitor and things like this also
have some possibility to do chaos chaos
test especially lambda functions and you
if you're using databases on AWS we
support this kind of testing file overs
and also we support query injection
fault injection directly on the database
that's for Aurora is our sequel database
that is Postgres and my sequel
compatible and you can simply run
comments like this this view of them you
can run and there's a list here this is
the comment to add a percentage of dis
failures in your in your database and
see how your application is going to
behave finally if you are into a lambda
and server less I wrote a chaos library
using lambda layers so that you can
inject licensee in either in the lambda
function itself or through methods and
decorators in Python that you can put on
top of your function and add latency so
that you can see how your code behaves
at scale and there's a whole blog post
written on that it's also a table
account together with all the code and
the stuff I deploy today so you can see
how bad I write code and how much work
it is to do on resiliency I want to
finish on some of the challenges with
chaos engineering because if you start
the practice of chaos engineering you
will have challenges as I say a loner is
my baby
well most code developers will behave
like that that means that if you
criticize or find faults in their codes
they will usually take it very
personally which is stupid because the
whole point of writing code is actually
to improve it and make it resilient and
there's no one way of doing it usually
is great but naturally people that write
code including myself always have this
fear of being criticized so in the early
days of chaos engineering practices make
sure that you kind of take a soft
approach to to pointing out problems
never ever blame anyone blame less
cultures are very very important and you
know it also is not going to replace
normal testing this is super important
to point out a lot I've seen folks mmm
focusing on caves engineering and then
they'd honestly support functional
testing all this kind of stuff
it doesn't mean you have to have 100%
coverage you know this hundred percent
but I think it's tools and things that
definitely test and try different things
a new system will actually continue
failing because that's just what it is
so the problem is a mostly cultural as I
say it will often highlight a choice of
the bad framework or Pythian versus Ruby
or C++ versus c-sharp or a Java versus
the rest of the world it's often like
that
but at the end of the day if you if you
are patient and if you work through
culture is actually make sure that you
don't blame people and that's what I
want to finish on I wouldn't be here
myself if I wouldn't have a blameless
culture before joining AWS actually I
clean database in production once a few
times and cleaning means deleting and my
manager never ever blamed me you must
say how this this happen that we could
run comments for deleting database in
production and what kind of how can we
prevent that and then we went into
building sets of tools to actually
prevent doing these kind of things and
this is how I started with chaos
engineering and building tools things
around preventing problems versus
blaming the people doing those stuff
because one day or another you look
gonna do the mistake anyway so don't do
it thank you so much for your time
hopefully inspire you to start or look a
bit further with with case engineering
you can directly download these
presentations with all the the links on
that one it's already uploaded there I
should definitely have done a QR code
but then your phone would have been
overloaded with the presentation and
I'll push that on my Twitter account as
well at the horn that link so that you
can also use the on Twitter and don't
hesitate to contact me I'm happy to
discuss about chaos resiliency and all
that stuff that's what I do for a living
so thank you again
you